foreign
to take a return
to factor your friends let's do it
we gotta is that the new grass look at
the new graphic it looks fantastic man I
know it looks awesome yeah
if you're listening to this on podcasts
some brand new graphics are behind me
it's awesome hey and for everybody
reaching out um this comes out you know
several weeks after we record it but we
changed the
podcast feed photo to more like an old
punk rock cover and man everybody's
reached out
I'm so grateful everybody's super
positive about it I love it I love it
it's finally feeling like more like home
more like me so that's that's fantastic
all right so today we are talking about
this
um this occurred to me about 10 years
ago working at University
um and my students were coming in and
coming in and coming in and this is when
10 to 15 years ago is when the a shift
begin to happen inside my dean of
students office
um my res life offices when I was
sitting with these students who were
really struggling and so many of the
struggles came down to financial
struggles
like at the end of the day I've got ADHD
I've got depression I've got this I've
got anxiety I'm struggling with this I'm
struggling with this I'm struggling with
this and it would always distill down to
we can't afford to be here
and I realized that the root of of that
money question was I'm about to lose all
my friends in community I'm about to get
off track and have to leave school and I
don't know what comes next my mom and
dad are hassling me all the time because
they can't afford College I can't afford
this place
so that's where that's the organic
nature of this conversation started with
me and at the same time I was getting my
graduate degree my wife was Dr deloney
before I was and so we had six degrees
between us
um we both had bachelor's degrees and
master's degrees and phds and we just
paid for them straight through and I
realized I could use my student loan
money to pay rent to I use them as like
a consolidation loan and I put all my
truck and my credit cards I put
everything in this big bucket and
I looked up all of a sudden and we owed
six figures we owed a hundred some
thousand dollars into the government
right in student loans and then my wife
and I both got fancy jobs
so we had to get new cars and so uh I
bought two cars we had I had an F-150 on
payments and I had got my wife a RAV4 uh
on payments and we've by the way we've
never been cool car people those those
cars for us were like whoa because we
don't care and then of course we had to
buy a new house so we got a house
and when I traced the timeline back when
I backed out 30 000 feet
from
what I would call when I just fell apart
I had a lot of anxiety a lot and I had
some trauma hadn't dealt with I had some
relationship issues I hadn't dealt with
I had some some major issues where trust
was broken in my life in some powerful
ways that I was still wrestling with
but when I drilled down to the
neurophysiology what was my brain trying
to tell me
screaming at the top of its lungs trying
to get my attention
sounding those anxiety alarms my heart
is racing every
it's my body new hey you owe a hundred
and ten or 106 whatever 110
000 in educational expenses that you can
never discharge with bankruptcy you are
stuck you will pay these off forever
five to six to seven hundred bucks a
month hey you owe on these depreciating
assets you owe ten thousand dollars on
this one and twenty thousand or
seventeen thousand on this one
you can't even afford a house oh you
just bought a house that's another
hundred and sixty thousand so we owed
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and it never occurred to me until
looking back in retrospect that my body
knew I worked at a university right as
all these conversations about hey you
can't say that you're gonna lose your
job all those things were starting
my body knew hey Delona you're kind of a
loud mouth and if you say the wrong
thing
you're gonna get fired if you get fired
your family loses their house they lose
their cars you all won't be able to eat
you have a new son now you have a kid
everything changes and so my body knew
my foot my my prefrontal cortex if you
will my PFC I'll simplify it
um it knew hey I got a good deal on the
APR on this my interest rate on my house
was pretty low my interest rate on my
student loans was pretty high but it
just globally it was pretty low
um my interest rate on my cars wasn't
bad so my brain my my thinking brain
knew I got some good deals on this stuff
but
for simplicity's sake my amygdala the
part of my brain that is sounding the
alarms that is always scanning the
environment all of the time
to let me know I'm not safe
right you ever walk into a room and you
just know I need to get out of here
or a guy walks into a room and you just
know your body knows that guy's not safe
that guy's not okay
or
um you grew up in an abusive household
and then another guy comes swaggering in
to some party you're in and you just
your body's like get out now like
that was ringing off the hook for me all
the time
and when your alarms are going off and
you don't know what they're what they're
from like why they're going off
it comes out as anger
comes out as blame well if you would
just pick everything up well if you
would just do this if those people
whoever those people happen to be if
they would just fill in the blank I
Don't Care What They're I don't care
what you're gonna say
if that if that if that political party
would
all of those feelings are your body
trying to get your attention
and because we have
um the
media industrial complex that we have
now always just spoon feeding us stories
as to why our bodies feel that way over
and over it's because of this it's
because of this it's because of this
I was talking in my one of my close
buddies uh Dr Lane Norton the other day
then the number of insane
insane
things people reach out to him for
for weight loss ideas and how to how to
get in shape how to how to lose body fat
it it will Boggle your mind people will
do anything
to not just
um um
eat less than they need and uh or eat
exactly what they need controller
calories and exercise people they'll go
to the ends of the Earth similarly
we will blame we will point fingers we
will create new things we will get
really really busy we will drink we will
just Netflix ourselves to death we will
like hide behind academic journals which
is what I did for years and years and
years we will do anything and our body
is screaming us and screaming us and
screaming us and so one of the keys here
and um
I don't want this to sound like a long
book pitch this is me just trying to
teach a little bit
one of the keys that I write about in
building a non-interest life one of the
choices we have to make on a daily basis
on a monthly basis on a weekly basis on
an annual based on a life basis is this
idea of choosing freedom
and I need you to hear me say
um
if you don't owe anybody any money
your body goes
you can get fired and they're not going
to take away your house
to take away your cars
you work for yourself and business can
slow to a crawl
and it's annoying it's not catastrophic
and
you've heard me say over and over the
title of the great Bessel vanderkolk's
book the body keeps the score but the
body keeps the score
and no matter how good you think I'm not
gonna pay off my mortgage because it's
at a three percent rate and I can invest
the rest over here cool go go do those
mathematical gymnastics do a bunch of
cartwheels with your calculators and
make yourself feel good your brain knows
we owe three hundred thousand dollars on
this mortgage and we're not safe
there's a reason why all throughout
human history
tribes and family lineages when they got
property it was passed down for
Generations I'll never forget a
conversation I had with a sociologist
from Romania we were sitting by each
other in a
climate science meeting and we were
talking about soil and stuff like that
in the United States and she leaned over
to me and she said I will never
understand the US's relationship to its
soil and I thought she was talking about
uh you know the poison we spray on our
foods and all that she wasn't
she said in in her home country
you had to prove lineage to buy land it
was that precious
you can't just sell it to anybody you
want to from any other country you can
just give that away that's so precious
that's what keeps us safe because it's
ours our bodies are able to go
when all else fails I can go home
and when you owe money to somebody
your body knows
and if we want to take the the choose
Freedom argument one step further
how many of you your your in-laws are
still telling you what you're going to
do for the holidays
how many of you still have friends that
are like oh my gosh Are you seriously
going to wear that we're going out on
Wednesday and you don't want to go
you're tired you miss your husband you
miss your wife you want to see your kids
actually
but you go anyway because you Outsource
that how many of you work at a toxic
workplace I know millions of you do
because I hear from you my friend can't
call and hears from you
all over the country
every month Monday your heart beat your
heart rate your BPM just goes up 10
beats because it's like ah here we go
man
I gotta go into this awful place
when you Outsource your joy when you
Outsource your life when you Outsource
how you feel when you Outsource your
thoughts your body keeps the score
or how many of you your lives are
dictated by what the soccer coach says
your practice schedule is going to be
how many of you are your lives are
dictated by what your pastor says your
church schedule and your evening
schedule and your weekend schedule all
like they run your calendar for you
how many of you are so up to your
eyeballs and school activities in karate
and horseback riding that your calendar
is so chaotic you're not free
and so
one of these core chapters in this book
one of these choices we have to make is
I got to choose freedom I have to look
at places in my life where I am hooked
then I have to consciously do the work
to unhook myself that might mean I gotta
spend five years working three jobs so
that I owe nobody anything
that might mean I'm gonna owe nobody
anything so that I can quit this job
that is killing me and go do something
else I'm going to sit down with my wife
and I'm going to we're going to clear
our calendar we're going to start to
finish or I'm single I'm going to get
with three or four of my friends one or
two of my friends we're going to go
through our calendar start to finish
what do I have to do
what do I want to do
and then we're going to backfill the
rest and that may mean looking at your
kids and saying hey this this year we're
stopping the madness we're just gonna do
one thing
you can play soccer you can do violin
you can do piano we're gonna do one
thing or you can do one instrument and
you can do one activity that's it
but we're gonna save the money we're
gonna save our life
hear me say this a Cornerstone of
building a non-anxious life
choosing freedom
and I don't mean that in the political
sense I don't mean that in the
um
I don't know dramatic sense
I mean literally
and I was in Costa Rica recently
and I'll leave you with this
my son and I were walking down down down
this sidewalk in this really busy street
and people are bustling and going and
going bustling and there's a lot of
motorcycles driving by and
he said dad this just feels different
here
I was like yeah you're right man and I
thought it was because because we were
on a trip
and then I said you know what Hank
everyone we've talked to
is so insanely proud to live here
they're so insanely proud of their
community
and where we were staying was at the
base of a giant volcano that's active
it's erupted within the last however
many years
and I would ask folks just from the
folks who were you know carrying bags to
the folks who were like the the leaders
and the restauranteers
like what happens if that thing goes off
and they were like
well this is over
it was just this and I was like yeah but
but
they had completely unhooked from this
obsession with we have to control
everything all the time everything's
about
it was just hey right now we live in
Beauty
we don't know anybody anything
our our cultural ethos is kindness and
Hospitality everybody's welcome
I'm not gonna fight you
we are just going to be at peace and if
you need some fruit off my tree you can
come grab it
every Community uh every every little
neighborhood every Community every
little town had four things had a church
a bar a school and a soccer field and I
thought man that may be good maybe that
may be the key to life
but I tell you all that to say I met
with people who had very very little
who sat at the base of a big volcano
that can go off at any time
and they were completely free they had
chosen freedom
they had chosen to let go the wheel
they don't know anybody thing
they weren't beholden to
and so if you want to live a non-anxious
life I want you to look around your life
I want you to look around your
relationships where are you not free
write those things down
be specific I owe a whole bunch of money
I live in an unsafe neighborhood I'm in
an unsafe scary marriage and I'm not
free to say what I think to let my needs
be heard I'm not free to walk about my
house
where are you not free
and if you've got a group of friends or
a partner who will sit with you and kind
of unpack those awesome if you don't
find a minister find a counselor find
somebody in your life you can sit on and
talk to
call my friends a better help reach out
to somebody
and say I'm not safe
not free
so that's today's facts of your friends
that's one of six of the choices you can
make pick up building a non-anxious life
go to jonalyn.com pick it up but
even if you don't buy the book that's
fine
I want this for you
I can't want it more than you do but I
really want it for you
I want you to choose freedom
choose
peace